Muchas veces me preguntan,
¿sabes qué es lo que más te sorprende acerca tu libro?
yo siempre respondo, que haya llegado a escribirlo.
Jamás me lo hubiera imaginado,
Ni siquiera en mi sueño más descabellado --
Ni siquiera me considero un autor.
Y me preguntan con mucha frequencia,
¿Por qué crees que tanta gente ha leido tu libro?
Todavía se venden cerca de un millón de copias al mes.
Yo creo que es porque el vacío espiritual
es una enfermedad universal.
Yo creo que en algún momento de nuestras vidas, ponemos nuestra cabeza en la almohada y nos preguntamos,
"La vida no puede ser solamente esto, tiene que haber mucho más".
Nos levantamos por la mañana, vamos al trabajo, regresamos a casa, miramos televisión
nos acostamos, nos despertamos por la mañana, vamos al trabajo, regresamos a casa, miramos televisión, dormimos,
vamos a fiestas en los fines de semana.
Y mucha gente dice, "Estoy viviendo". "No, tú no estás viviendo, estás simplemente existiendo".
Simplemente existiendo.
Yo realmente creo que hay un deseo interior.
Creo firmemente en lo que Cristo dijo. Tu existencia no es una casualidad.
Puede que tus padres no te hayan planeado, pero creo que Dios sí.
No hay duda de que hay personas que llegan a ser padres por accidente.
Pero no creo en niños que vienen a este mundo por casualidad.
Creo que tú eres muy importante.
Creo que tú le importas a Dios, creo que tú le importas a la historia,
creo que tú le importas a este universo.
Y creo que la diferencia entre
lo que yo llamo una vida de sobrevivencia, una vida de éxito
y una vida de sentido es,
el hecho de comprender, ¿cuál es la razón de mi existencia?
He conocido muchas personas muy inteligentes que dicen,
"¿Por qué aún soy tan incapaz de resolver mis problemas?"
Y también he conocido mucha gente exitosa que dice,
"¿Por qué no me siento más realizado?"
¿Por qué me siento como un farsante?
¿Por qué siento que
siempre tengo que estar pretendiendo ser más de lo que realmente soy?"
Creo que esto se resume en el asunto de llevar una vida de sentido, de trascendencia, de propósito.
Creo que todo se reduce a esta pregunta:
¿Por qué estoy aquí? ¿Para qué estoy aquí? ¿Para dónde voy?
Estas no son temas religiosos --
son temas humanos.
Quería decirle a Michael antes de que él hablara
que sinceramente aprecio lo que él hace,
porque facilita mi vida en gran manera.
Como pastor, es muy normal ver muchos lunáticos
pero al mismo tiempo me he dado cuenta de que hay lunáticos en todas las áreas de la vida.
La religión no tiene un
monopolio en esta area, aunque sí hay un sinnúmero de lunáticos religiosos.
Existen los lunáticos seculares, los lunáticos inteligentes, los lunáticos ridículos
Un día una señora se me acercó,
ella llevaba una hoja de papel en blanco-- Michael, te va a gustar esto--
y me pregunta, "¿Qué ves en esta hoja de papel?"
Yo la ojeé y le respondí, "Oh, no veo nada".
Y ella me dice, "Bueno, yo veo a Jesús", y enseguida comenzó a llorar y se marchó.
Yo digo, OK, tu sabes. Está bien.
Hum.
Me alegro por ti.
Cuando el libro se convirtió en un éxito editorial en todo el mundo durante los últimos tres años,
Yo tuve mi pequeña crisis.
En ese entonces me preguntaba, ¿Cuál es el propósito de todo esto?
Ya que me comenzó a entrar una cantidad enorme de dinero.
Cuando escribes un éxito editorial mundial,
recibes muchísimo dinero, además de que
acaparas mucha atención y, al decir verdad, yo no quería ninguno de las dos cosas.
Cuando establecí la Iglesia en Saddleback, yo tenía 25 años de edad.
La comencé en 1980 juntamente con otra familia
en ese tiempo tomé la decision de nunca aparecer en televisión
porque no tenía ningún deseo de convertirme en una celebridad
y tampoco quería tornarme en un, entre comillas, "evangelista o evangelista de televisión" --
No es lo mío.
Y de repente, me llega muchísimo dinero y atención.
No creo que --
Ahora, esta es mi visión del mundo, y te digo, todos tienen una visión del mundo.
Todo el mundo está apostando su vida por algo.
Tu estás apostando tu vida por algo --
Y más vale que sepas por qué estás apostando en lo que estás apostando.
Así, pues, todo el mundo apuesta su vida por algo.
En mi caso, cuando hice mi apuesta, yo creía
que Jesús era aquél quien él decía ser.
Y todos apuestan -- y creo en una sociedad pluralista --
todos están apostando por algo.
Cuando comencé la iglesia,
no había previsto que fuera a convertirse en lo que es actualmente.
y cuando escribí este libro años más tarde,
de repente simplemente
levantó vuelo,
y empecé a preguntarme, ¿Cuál es el propósito de todo esto?
Porque al mismo tiempo comencé a decir,
No creo que tu recibas tanto dinero y tanta fama
para alimentar tu propio ego, jamás.
Estoy convencido de que no es así.
y cuando tú escribes un libro que comienza con la frase:
"no se trata ti",
y cuando, de repente,
se convierte en el libro de mayor venta en la historia,
supongo que, de hecho, no se trata de ti.
es obvio, no hay que darle tantas vueltas al asunto.
entonces, ¿cuál es la razón de todo esto?
Fue en ese momento que comencé a pensar acerca de la mayordomía de la opulencia
y la mayordomía de la influencia.
Yo creo que el liderazgo es esencialmente una mayordomía.
Que si tú eres un líder en cualquier area --
ya sea en los negocios, en la política, en los deportes, en el arte,
en el campo académico, en cualquier area --
tú no eres el dueño de ella,
tú eres, más bien, un mayordomo de ella.
Por ejemplo, yo creo en la protección del medio ambiente.
La tierra no me pertenece. Tampoco era mía cuando nací.
y no va a ser mía después de que muera.
Voy a estar aquí solamente por 80 años.
Hace algunos días participé en un programa de entrevistas,
en el cual uno de los asistentes a manera de desafío me preguntó,
"¿Qué hace un pastor protegiendo el medio ambiente?"
Entonces le pregunté, "bien, tú crees que
los seres humanos deberían asumir la responsabilidad
de hacer del mundo un lugar mejor para las próximas generaciones?
¿tú crees que tenemos la mayordomía
de tomar en serio al medio ambiente?"
a lo que él respondió, "No".
"Oh, ¿no crees?", le pregunté, "entonces déjame aclararte la pregunta".
Tú crees que como seres humanos -- y no me estoy refieriendo a la religión --
tú crees que como seres humanos, es nuestra responsabilidad
de cuidar este planeta y hacer de él un mejor lugar para las generaciones futuras?"
Y él respondió, "No".
no tenemos más responsabilidad que cualquier otra especie".
Al mencionar la palabra "especies", él estaba revelando su visión del mundo.
y continuó, "no tengo más responsabilidad de cuidar del medio ambiente
que un pato".
Claro, yo sé que muchas veces sí actuamos como patos,
pero no eres un pato.
tú no eres un pato.
y tú sí eres responsable -- esa es mi visión del mundo.
Tú tienes que entender cuál es tu mundo, tu visión del mundo.
El problema es que la mayoría de las personas nunca reflexiona acerca de este asunto cabalmente.
La mayoría de las personas nunca
lo codifican o cualifican o cuantifican,
de tal manera que puedan decir, "Yo creo firmemente en esto o aquello.
Y creo en esto por ésta o aquella razón".
Yo personalmente no tengo la fe suficiente para ser un ateista.
Pero puede que tú si la tengas.
Tu visión del mundo va a determinar todo en tu vida,
porque determina tus decisiones,
determina tus relaciones,
determina tu nivel de confianza.
Realmente determina todo en tu vida.
Lo que creemos, obviamente --
y ustedes lo saben muy bien -- determina nuestro comportamiento,
y nuestro comportamiento determina lo que seremos en la vida.
Así que el dinero me comenzó a llegar a raudales,
al igual que mucha fama,
entonces me comencé a preguntar, ¿qué voy a hacer con todo esto?
Mi esposa y yo tomamos cinco decisiones en cuanto a qué a hacer con el dinero.
Dijimos, "primero",
no lo vamos a usar para nuestro propio beneficio".
No nos compramos una casa más grande.
o una casa de huéspedes.
Todavía manejo el mismo Ford viejo de hace cuatro años.
Sencillamente dijimos, no vamos a usar este dinero para nosotros.
La segunda decision que tomamos fue,
Parar de devengar el salario de la iglesia que pastoreo.
En tercer lugar, calculamos el total de todo el dinero que la iglesia me había pagado a lo largo de los últimos 25 años,
y lo devolvimos en su totalidad.
Lo hice porque no quería que nadie fuera a pensar que
lo que hago lo hago por causa del dinero -- no es así.
De hecho, personalmente nunca he conocido a ningún
sacerdote o pastor o ministro que trabaje por causa del dinero.
Yo sé que es un estereotipo, pero nunca he conocido ni siquiera a uno.
Créanme, hay muchas otras maneras mucho más fáciles de ganar dinero.
Los pastores son como los doctores, deben estar a disposición las 24 horas del día.
Hoy salí de mi casa tarde. Estaba planeando venir aquí ayer,
pero no pude porque mi suegro está pasando probablemente por sus últimas 48 horas de vida
antes de que muera de cancer.
El es una persona que ha vivido una larga vida --
Ya está en sus 80 --
y ahora está muriendo en paz. La prueba de tu visión del mundo
no es cómo actúas en los buenos tiempos.
La prueba de tu visiòn del mundo es cómo actúas en tu funeral.
Después de haber presidido cientos o inclusive miles de funerarios,
me he dado cuenta de que sí hace una gran diferencia.
tus creencias marcan la diferencia.
Así que, nosotros devolvimos todo,
y después establecimos tres fundaciones
para ayudar a resolver los mayores problemas mundiales:
el analfabetismo, la pobreza, las epidemias -- particularmente HIV/AIDS --
De manera que creamos estas tres fundaciones,
e invertimos el dinero en ellas.
Finalmente nos convertimos en "diezmeros inversos".
Cuando mi esposa y yo nos casamos,
hace 30 años,
comenzamos a diezmar.
El diezmo es un principio bíblico
el cual dice que debemos separar un 10 por ciento para obras de caridad,
y donarlo para ayudar a otras personas.
Así que cuando comenzamos a diezmar, también decidimos aumentar el diezmo en 1 por ciento cada año.
así es como en el primer año de nuestro matrimonio logramos dar 11 por ciento,
en el segundo año, diezmamos 12 por ciento,
y en el tercer año 13 por ciento,
y así sucesivamente. Ahora, ¿por qué decidí hacer ésto?
Porque cada vez que doy,
más me libero del control que el materialismo ejerce en mi vida.
El materialismo consiste solamente en adquirir cosas -- adquirir todo lo que más puedas.
Consiste en amontonar riquezas y sentarse en ellas sin que nos importe nada más.
Consiste en poseer cada vez más.
Creemos que tener una buena vida es tener una buena apariencia.
creemos que lo más importante es lucir bien,
sentirnos bien y poseer cuantiosos bienes.
Pero esa no es la buena vida.
Yo continuamente conozco a personas que tienen estas cosas,
y no son necesariamente felices.
Si el dinero realmente pudiera concederte la felicidad,
entonces los más ricos en el mundo serían los más felices.
Y yo sé, personalmente, que ése no es el caso.
Sencillamente no es verdad.
La buena vida no radica en tener buena apariencia, sentirse bien o en poseer muchos bienes,
Se trata de ser bueno y hacer el bien.
Se trata de sacrificar tu vida.
El sentido en la vida no tiene que ver con el estatus,
porque siempre vas a encontrar a alguien que tiene más bienes que tú.
Tampoco se origina en el sexo.
No proviene del salario.
Proviene de servir.
Dando nuestras vidas es como encontramos sentido,
encontramos significación.
Estamos hechos así, yo creo, por Dios.
Así, pues, empezamos a donar,
y ahora después de 30 años,
mi esposa y yo somos diezmeros inversos -- es decir, donamos 90 % y vivimos con 10%
Y esto, de hecho, fue lo más fácil.
Lo difícil es, ¿qué hacer con toda la atención que recibí después.
Porque me comenzaron a llegar todo tipo de invitaciones.
De hecho, acabé de regresar de una gira de charlas de casi un més
en tres continentes diferentes,
sobre la cual no voy a comentar ahora,
pero les puedo decir que fue algo extraordinario.
Así que yo me preguntaba, ¿Qué hago con todo esto,
con la notoriedad que el libro me ha traido?
Y ya que soy un pastor, lógicamente empecé a leer la Biblia.
Hay un capítulo en la Biblia llamado Salmo 72,
el cual es una oración hecha por Salomón para ganar más influencia.
Cuando lees esta oración,
pareciera que fuera increiblemente egocentrica,
Pareciera que él dijera,
"Dios, quiero que me conviertas en alguien famoso".
Y esa es precisamente la oración que él hace.
El dice, "quiero que me hagas famoso.
Quiero que la fama de mi nombre sea divulgada a través de toda la tierra,
Quiero que me concedas poder,
Quiero que me hagas famoso.
Quiero que me confieras influencia".
Pareciera que ésta fuera la petición más egoísta que alguien pudiera hacer
al momento de orar.
Esto es, hasta cuando lees todo el salmo, el capítulo entero.
Después él dice, "Para que el rey" --
él era el rey de Israel durante el apogeo de esta nación --
"para que el rey pueda atender a las viudas y huérfanos,
dar consuelo a los desanimados, defender a los oprimidos, cuidar a los enfermos,
ayudar a los pobres, abogar por los extranjeros
y aquellos que están en prisión".
Básicamente, él se refiere a todos los marginados en la sociedad.
Y en cuanto leía este pasaje,
pensaba, bien,
el propósito de tener influencia es para defender
a aquellos que no la tienen.
El propósito de tener influencia no es para edificar tu ego,
o aumentar tu patrimonio neto.
Y, por cierto, tu patrimonio neto no es igual
a tu autoestima.
Tu valor no se basa en el valor de tus bienes,
Se basa en algo totalmente distinto.
Entonces el objetivo de la influencia es defender
a aquellos que no la tienen.
Y tuve que que admitir que
no me acuerdo cuándo fue la última vez que pensé en viudas y huérfanos.
Ellos no están en mi radar.
La iglesia que yo pastoreo está en una de las áreas más acaudaladas de America--
una área llena de condominios privados.
A mi iglesia asisten científicos y gerentes de empresas (CEOs)
Y fácilmente podría pasar 5 años sin nunca ver un indigente
Porque ellos no están en mi camino.
Aunque están a 21 kms de distancia en Santa Ana.
Así que dije, "bien,
voy a usar toda la afluencia e influencia que tengo para
ayudar a aquellos que no tienen ninguna de las dos".
En la Biblia hay una historia acerca de Moisés.
si ustedes creen que es verídica o no --
la verdad no importa mucho aquí.
Si vieron la película "Los Dies Mandamientos", se acordarán que
Moisés un día ve un arbusto ardiente por el cual Dios le habla.
Dios le pregunta, "¿Moisés,
Qué tienes en tu mano?"
Esa es una de las preguntas más importantes que te podrán hacer.
¿Qué hay en tu mano?
Moisés responde, "un cayado.
Es un cayado para pastorear ovejas".
Y Dios le dice, "Arrójalo al suelo".
Si vieron el filme, sabrán que cuando el lo lanza al suelo el cayado se convierte en una serpiente.
Dios después le dice, "recógela".
Y cuando Moisés la recoge,
la serpiente se convierte en un cayado nuevamente.
Mientras yo leía este pasaje me preguntaba, ¿Qué significa todo esto?
¿Cuál es el significado de esta historia? Aquí hay dos puntos muy importantes.
Primeramente, Dios nunca hace un milagro para lucirse.
El no lo hace simplemente para que digamos, "¡Vaya, qué impresionante!"
Y, a propósito, mi Dios no tiene necesidad de aparecerse en un pan de queso.
Porque si El ha de aparecerse,
No lo va a hacer en un pan de queso.
(Risas)
¿No lo creen? Por eso es que me encanta lo que Michael hace,
porque si él va a desmitificar algo, entonces yo no tengo que hacerlo.
Pero Dios -- mi Dios -- no tiene necesidad de mostrarse en imágenes de aspersores de agua.
El tiene otras maneras mucho más poderosas
para llevar a cabo lo que Él quiere realizar.
Sin embargo, Él no hace milagros simplemente para presumir.
En segundo lugar, si Dios alguna vez te pregunta algo,
El ya sabe la respuesta.
Evidentemente, si El es Dios, eso significa que
cuando El te hace una pregunta, lo hace por tu bien y no por el de Él.
Entonces, Dios le pregunta a Moisés, "¿Qué tienes en tu mano?"
¿Y qué tenía Moisés en la mano?
Tenía un cayado para pastorear ovejas. Ahora, quiero que me presten bien atención.
Este cayado representaba tres cosas acerca de la vida de Moisés.
Primero, representaba su propia identidad.
El era un pastor. Era el símbolo de su ocupación.
El era un pastor. Es un símbolo de su indentidad, de su profesión, de su trabajo.
Segundo, el cayado es un símbolo no solamente de su identidad,
sino también de sus ingresos, ya que todos sus bienes estaban ligados a sus ovejas.
En ese tiempo nadie tenía cuentas bancarias,
o tarjetas de crédito American Express o fondos de cobertura.
Sus bienes estaban conectados a sus rebaños.
El cayado era un símbolo de su identidad como también de sus ingresos.
Tercero, el cayado es un símbolo de su influencia.
¿Para qué es el cayado?
Bueno, en primera instancia, tú lo utilizas para mobilizar a las ovejas de un lugar a otro,
ya sea con un gancho o con una percha.
O las jalas o las empujas, o lo uno o lo otro.
Lo que Dios está diciendo aquí es,
"Vas a despojarte de tu propia identidad".
¿Qué tienes en tu mano? ¿Tu identidad, tu salario, tu influencia?
¿Qué hay en tu mano?"
Y Dios dice, "Si te despojas de él, voy a ser que cobre vida.
Y haré cosas inimaginables".
Y si miraron la película "Los Diez Mandamientos",
todos esos grandes milagros que ocurrieron en Egipto
fueron hechos a través de este cayado.
El año pasado, fui invitado a dar una charla en el juego de las estrellas de la NBA.
Cuando les estaba hablando a los jugadores,
ya que la mayoría de los equipos de la NBA, NFL, entre otros
han practicado los "40 Días de Propósito" basados en el libro.
Entonces, les preguntaba, "Qué tienen en su mano?
¿Qué tienen en su mano?" Y les decía, "es un balón de baloncesto,
el baloncesto representa su identidad, lo que ustedes son.
Como jugadores de la NBA, el balón también representa el salario que se ganan.
Y ustedes ganan mucho dinero por medio de ese pequeño balón.
El balón también representa la influencia que poseen.
y aunque solamente estarán en la NBA por algunos años,
de todas maneras serán jugadores de la NBA todas sus vidas.
Y ese hecho les confiere una influencia enorme.
¿Qué piensan hacer con todo lo que han recibido?"
Y esa es la razón principal por la cual yo vine aquí hoy.
Les quiero preguntar a todos ustedes, gente brillante de TED,
"¿Qué tienen en sus manos?"
¿Qué tienen en sus manos que les fue dado?
Talento, trasfondo, educación,
libertad, conecciones, oportunidades,
riqueza, ideas, creatividad.
¿Qué estás haciendo
con aquello que has recibido?
Para mí, esa es la pregunta más fundamental de la vida.
y eso es lo que significa ser personas de propósito en la vida.
En el libro, hablo acerca de como nosotros estamos hechos para ciertas cosas
Esta pequeña cruz requiere dones espirituales, corazón,
habilidad, personalidad y experiencias.
Estas cosas te moldean.
Y si anhelas saber que deberías estar haciendo en tu vida,
Debes mirarte a tí mismo, a tu forma. ¿Para qué fui diseñado yo?
¿Por qué Dios me diseñaría para algo
sin permitir que lo realice en mi vida?
Si fuiste hecho para ser un antropólogo, serás un antropólogo.
si fuiste hecho para ser un explorador bajo la superficie del mar,
entonces serás tal explorador.
Si fuiste diseñado para hacer negocios, haces negocios.
Si tu llamado es la pintura, entonces pinta.
¿Sabías que Dios sonríe cuando tú eres tú mismo?
Cuando mis hijos eran muy pequeños --
ya todos crecieron, y ahora hasta tengo nietos --
Solía sentarme al lado de sus camas,
para contemplarlos mientras dormían.
Y miraba como sus cuerpitos subían y bajaban,
subían y bajaban.
Y mientras los miraba, pensaba, esto no es un accidente.
Subir y bajar.
Me daba mucha alegría verlos durmiendo.
Algunas personas tienen la idea errónea de que Dios solamente está satisfecho
cuando hacemos, entre comillas, "cosas espirituales",
tales como asistir a reuniones de la iglesia o ayudar a los pobres,
o confesarnos o cosas por el estilo.
En resumidas cuentas, Dios se complace en verte siendo tú mismo. ¿Por qué?
El te hizo. Y cuando tú haces lo que fuiste diseñado para hacer,
El dice, "Ese es mi hijo.
Ese es mi hija.
Tú estás empleando los talentos y habilidades que te di".
El consejo que les doy es,
Miren lo que hay en sus manos --
identidad, influencia, salario --
y díganse, "Esto no es solo para mí.
Esto es para hacer del mundo un lugar mejor".
Gracias.